silmarils anatar kelebrimbor does this
sound like gibberish to you fear not
here's everything you need to know about
the rings of power
before you get into the history of the
rings of power it's important to
understand just how important jewelry in
general is to tolkien's mythos you don't
have to get far into the author's works
to realize that precious metals and
stones play a vital role in middle
earth's history for example the
silmarillion is literally named after
three powerful gems that glow with their
own light and spark a multi-century war
between the elves and the first dark
lord morgoth the lord of the rings also
mentions jewelry in its title referring
to sauron's one ring and the 19
additional rings of power and then there
are the numerous necklaces scepters
rings gems and other trinkets that pop
up regularly in the text aragorn's
family heirloom the ring of bar here is
one of them in peter jackson's films
arwen gives the evenstar a precious
necklace to aragorn while thorin goes
mad looking for the arkanstone in the
hobbit this obsession with jewelry makes
sense given tolkien's love of medieval
legends stories and fairy tales many of
which feature such valued treasures in
their narratives for all the bedazzled
fun going on in middle-earth however
there's no doubt that rings have a
particularly important part to play in
the author's world
while the rings of power are the most
powerful and important rings that appear
in the third age it's worth knowing that
they're not the only magical rings in
middle earth while token doesn't talk
about them in detail he makes it very
clear that there are other rings besides
the big 20. there are many magic rings
in this world bilbo baggins and none of
them should be used lightly there are a
couple of places where tolkien mentions
other rings the most obvious of these
can be found at the beginning of the
fellowship of the ring when gandalf
explains the backstory of the rings to
frodo and breaks the news to the
frightened hobbit that his little ring
is the one ring that sauron is avidly
pursuing the scene takes place in bag
end where gandalf calmly explains that
in the region of region the elves used
to make their own magical rings he
describes them as mere essays in the
craft compared to the rings of power but
warns that they still would have been
dangerous for mortals to wield
here's a question
where on earth do all of these powerful
rings come from and how do they end up
unevenly distributed between the various
races of middle earth well in
predictable fashion tolkien provided a
significant amount of information about
this seemingly minor detail via a story
that starts back in the second age of
middle earth at the beginning of the age
sauron takes over the role of the dark
lord from his master morgoth he keeps a
low profile for several centuries then
makes his first moves building up his
strength and choosing mordor is his
stomping ground but things don't move
quickly enough so he shapes himself into
an attractive physical appearance calls
himself anatar the lord of gifts and
pays a visit to the elves anatar
immediately tries to worm his way into
their affections by offering his very
real wisdom and skill as a craftsman one
group of elves who live in region are
more than a little appreciative of
anatar's rival and their leader keller
brimbour soaks up everything that he is
willing to teach eventually the elven
lord and his guild of craftsmen join up
with the lord of gifts and they all
begin forging a number of magic rings
while these rings would eventually end
up in the hands of men and dwarves at
this point they're solely considered
elven rings
after 16 of the rings of power are
forged sauron sneaks back into mordor
and crafts the one ring in the meantime
kala brimbore creates the three elven
rings using the techniques he had been
taught by anatar crucially however
sauron had nothing to do with their
creation and never once laid a hand on
them giving the three rings an element
of purity that isn't present in the
others even so keller bremborg couldn't
have made these without sauron's
mentorship and the silmarillion states
that even they were subject to the one
one ring to
[Music]
as soon as sauron puts on his new ring
the elves become aware of his presence
and take their rings off refusing to be
controlled by the new dark lord enraged
by his own failure sauron responds by
attacking oregon and seizing the nine
rings for himself he tortures
calibrimbore and before he dies the
elven lord reveals where seven of the
others are however he never tells sauron
where he sent the three elven rings
which remains safe and well hidden once
sauron has acquired most of the rings of
power he distributes them to the various
men and dwarves that he wants to
dominate with his will the dwarves end
up too stubborn to control but their
rings still corrupt their hearts and
drive them to become obsessed with
treasure men are much easier to sway and
the lords and kings who wield the rings
of power are turned into some of
sauron's most feared servants
sauron's greatest success is with the
nine rings which are given to a group of
mortal men the silmarillion explains the
extraordinary powers of this group of
wraiths saying that if they wanted to
they could walk unseen by anybody else
in the world and that they themselves
could see things nobody else could
as they walk in both the real world and
the wraith world these men slowly begin
to lose themselves one by one they fall
under the influence of the one ring
causing them to become permanently
invisible and driving them into total
thraldom to the power of mordor they
later become known as the nazgul these
wraiths remain sauron's fiercely loyal
servants throughout their unnaturally
long lives led by the witch king of
angmar they spread terror throughout
middle-earth right up until the moment
at which the one ring is finally
destroyed
much attention is often given to the
rings claimed by men and elves but you
don't often hear about a lot of those
wielded by the dwarves that's because
the dwarves aren't all that interested
in being dominated by anyone good or bad
in fact throughout the silmarillion they
consistently switch between the roles of
heroes and villains usually depending on
the situation that said when sauron
gives seven of the dwarf lords their own
rings of power it doesn't have quite the
effect that he hoped the silmarillion
says that the dwarves proved tough and
hard to tame and used their rings for
one purpose acquiring wealth the power
of the rings also causes the dwarves to
become obsessively possessive over their
treasures filling them with wrath and
hatred towards anybody who would
threaten them over the years these dwarf
lords grow seven hordes of treasure and
a golden ring is rumored to be at the
heart of each one sauron's influence
over the dwarves is limited however as
they can't be reduced to shadows their
wills can't be enslaved and their lives
aren't otherwise affected by the rings
even so things don't turn out
particularly well for the dwarven rings
sauron recovers three of them while the
remaining four are devoured by dragons
while this isn't quite what sauron
planned tolkien points out in the
silmarillion that the greed of gold
stirred in the hearts of these dwarves
proved to be quite useful to the dark
lord
next up you've got the three elven rings
these are special in a number of ways
first off they are the only rings of
power that are definitely forged outside
of sauron's influence he never touched
them during their creation and so they
are regarded as more pure than the
others even though the one ring is still
ultimately able to dominate them when
the one ring is lost though the elven
rings can be used for their original
purpose which is very different from the
other rings the silmarillion explains
that the three could ward off the decays
of time and postpone the weariness of
the world in this sense they are
instruments of preservation and healing
they're also by far the most magical
rings and their wielders use them to
inspire both life and hope in those who
live under them the elven rings pass
through a few owners over the years but
by the end of the third age they're kept
by three different people galadriel
guards nenia the ring of water this is
nenu the ring of adamant
and i am its keeper meanwhile elrod
keeps vilya the ring of air and gandalf
is given naria the ring of fire these
rings are often used to build havens of
peace and protection most notably
lothorian and rivendell as such sauron
greatly covets their unsullied power
even though he's never able to track
them down tolkien does make it clear
that despite their disconnect from
sauron's tampering the one ring is
powerful enough to dominate the three as
well in the lord of the rings he
explains that if the dark lord were to
get hold of the one ring all of the work
that had been done with the three would
be brought to ruin
finally the piece de resistance the one
ring this is the ultimate piece in the
middle earth jewelry box it isn't just a
ring of power like the others sauron
infuses this ring with his own will and
power to give it the strength to
dominate the others in the fellowship of
the ring the high stakes nature of the
one is laid bare in this book it's
pointed out that because he allowed a
significant portion of his power to pass
into it sauron can control any of the
others as long as he gets hold of the
one sauron needs only this ring to cover
all the lands of a second darkness
the one ring has a number of effects on
mortals too most famously it's able to
turn its wearer invisible it can also
bring them into the spiritual realm
gives them an understanding of different
languages and can extend their lives
indefinitely more than all the other
rings the one ring is also able to take
care of itself it can sense its master's
call and responds in very direct ways
doing things like changing sizes or even
abandoning its wearer the ones desired
to return to sauron is so strong in fact
that it can overcome the will of anyone
who possesses it
each of the rings of power has its own
story powerful properties and elements
of good or evil however the actual way
in which they work is something of a
mystery for one thing as you probably
know now each of them impacts their
owners in different ways take
invisibility for example neither dwarves
nor elves disappear due to the use of
their rings while men eventually become
creatures of ghostly terror and mortals
seem to vanish suddenly when they use
the one there's certainly no doubt that
the rings of power enhance the abilities
of their wares in some way or another
sometimes this is subtle such as making
it easier for the dwarves to cultivate
their wealth at other times it's very
direct like bilbo turning invisible to
fight giant spiders in mirkwood
throughout his writing about magic rings
though tolkien never seems to codify a
specific set of rules under which they
operate instead he uses their physical
abilities to hint at a much larger more
impressive and more spiritual element to
their magical powers the one theme that
is consistent across all of the rings
however is their domination and draw
toward the one ring this is even true
for the safer elven rings meanwhile the
rings of the men and dwarves are
outright cursed and perverted by sauron
the silmarillion simply states that in
the end all of the rings betrayed those
who used them while gandalf points out
in the fellowship of the ring that
anybody who wields a great ring will be
devoured by the dark power sooner or
later
[Music]
you